mainstream media and how you know male
stories and narratives are being kind of
feminized and they're being kind of
overshadowed and demeaned but I was
quite interested to think about say
China right which doesn't really run by
our standards and you see the same kind
of um Trend with pretty boys in China
that they've now banned so I'm just
curious as to what you think about how
that Trend can occur if you're in a
country where there's no feminists right
they've banned pretty boys lady boys
yeah because they think it's bad for the
states
like the K-pop
selected like well why did they ban them
I don't get it because they think it's
bad for young men in China and they
don't want it to affect their youth
China is making specific efforts to try
to make sure
people aren't willing to do they just
don't they just don't they say we don't
want men looking at guys who wear pink
suits and makeup and K-Pop Stars you
don't like that image we're going to
suppress that we want actual strong guys
so I was quite interested right because
China doesn't have a it's a Communist
party right yeah so and they've got busy
basically no feminists so who did that
is my is my question what you guys think
who made the feminine like the feminist
who made it okay wait wait wait how
could that trauma occur so in the west I
would have said is this feminization of
men there's a lot of reasons but part of
it is this feminist agenda pushing men
to cry more be more emotional pushing
this Narrative of women strong leaders
basically [ __ ] on men around them
and showing how you know girl power but
that doesn't happen in China so how come
China have the same issue of pretty boys
I don't think China has a massive issue
with pretty boys so why'd they Banner if
they don't have because they want to nip
it completely in the bud but why would
they nip it if it wasn't a problem like
if it looks because people still have
internet accessible people people can
people can still can still see things
you know you're always you've got 1.4
billion people in China but you know
what he's trying to get out sorry just
to clarify he's basically trying to get
to the point that you're saying that
feminist influences yeah you're blaming
women and feminism giving women too much
voice and he's saying actually in a
place where women don't have much voice
the same things are still happening so
the problem may not be with women the
problem may just be that men actually do
have a tendency to be someone no that's
not what I'm saying
I was just curious as to what what the
other components of that would be if
there's nothing and we don't have this
toxic Western culture attitude
why I mean I would say like it's pretty
boys everywhere that's not new it's
always been yeah I mean it's just
whether or not that's the standards
everywhere
because the women like that soft
emotional
male pretty male with the fancy here and
the pretty clothes trying the most well
you don't but thank you they're very
popular all around so maybe that's why
then they put it in the bud because they
don't want that sort of man representing
them exactly and maybe we should have
stopped the feminism this far right
feminism nipped it in the bud before it
started yeah
yeah there's different variations of
feminism and just because I kind of feel
like there needs to be equality it
doesn't necessarily make me a feminist I
feel like I'm a humanist
[Music]
yes the only reason like we said that
was because you're repeating like a
feminist argument which isn't which
isn't true we don't live in a patriarchy
women have more power than men
we really do honestly like like I just
think like girls that say that are lazy
and like need an excuse and like yeah
yeah I really I really do because we all
play a victim yeah because you're able
to acknowledge that there's an issue of
inequality no there's no way yeah
there's no issue with equality well I
know for a certain fact that a woman in
Iran right now just got murdered because
she wasn't wearing her her job properly
that's one way
and where and not wear appropriate
women's clothing in some areas you will
get lashed you know something like those
are the rules for that particular place
so if you know that those are the rules
for that particular place you abide by
the rules you went in Rome if I went
there and I decided to walk around in a
bikini I would expect to be punished so
if you go there to live by death but you
would know that before you go you
wouldn't because no that is your that is
place where you live when you're going
and traveling do you just go to other
countries and don't look it up
but the woman was Iranian the woman had
a headscarf on her head but she wasn't
wearing it according to someone else's
opinion correctly and so therefore does
that means is that a majority does it
happen yes
if you look at all the women in Iran
that wear hijabs how many percentage is
that a majority or is that a minority
whenever women are trying to it doesn't
matter whatever women are trying to find
something to like you know
um counteract what somebody says it
doesn't always go for the minority
for the majority it's like I need to be
right no no no no listen we only speak
like that I'll tell you something I'm
not saying that it's not an atrocity I'm
saying that it's an atrocity which is a
minority
only in the Western World can we
actually have the balls to say it is not
a man's world Africa Asia Latin American
I think even in the USA maybe only
Europe a little bit where there's not
really like that every single house it
is a man's world the only difference is
a man's weakness is a woman so in a
Mazel the woman does have the power but
it is still a man's world and if you
don't know how to use your power as a
woman then you're inferior and you
succumb to the fact that it's a man's
world and therefore you are unequal
can I can I jump in here with a
hopefully a moderating take is I think
these conversations vary very very
differently depending on if we're
talking about the modern West or if
we're talking about on a global scale
right I think even the concept of
feminism like I have respect for like
Middle Eastern feminists yeah right
feminism in the middle if you talk about
feminism in in the Middle East or in in
certain parts of Africa and so I'm like
I can respect that which is one reason
actually why when modern you know Anglo
women are there talking about we live in
a patriarchy it's like you're in Canada
or something I'm like let's just stop
like just just stop you're just you're
just whining right what more rights do
you want what more rights can you even
can you even get and what's funny is
oftentimes those so-called Western
feminists are very very quiet when it
does come to stuff around the globe
which you could have a legitimate case
of saying okay look at that that
situation is messed up that's not fair
that's truly an equal so I think the
global lens is very different to the
country injury that we are living years
ago I would have said that I was a
feminist now I say I'm a traditionalist
yeah yeah I would have said that as well
and then when you listen to how they
talk you realize that they're just like
in a state of constant hysteria like the
normal feminist take is to sit around
watching feminist blogs kind of uh
report on like some random thing that
happens to the woman in Australia and
then the feminist comes up and says
that's a sign of how the world is this
woman got killed by a kangaroo in
Australia which means kangaroos hate
women and there's a sexist problem
[Laughter]
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible